ونحييكم مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم دائما على
مدار الساعه في تغطيه التطورات المشهد
بالسودان فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
والله الوغود ضاع لنا
يعني
بضاعه جديده خالصه ما في دقيق بيجي ما في
اي حاجه هسه حاليا في الوقت الحالي ده
اسال الله يا اخي يرفع الناس
وفي اخر التطورات مع اقتراب انتهاء الهدنه
توصلوا لاطراف الدوليه الضغطه من اجل
تمديدها مع عدم وجود مؤشرات على موافقه
طرفي الصراع على ذلك حيث تبدل الطرفين اي
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع القذف
فيما دخل اقليم دارفور على خط الازمه مع
احتدام القتال في الاقليم المضطربي غرب
البلاد يتزامى ذلك مع مخاوف من كارثه تهدد
قطاعات عده في السودان وتزيد من معاناه
الشعب عدد القتلى في تزايد مع عمليه نزوح
ولجوء واسعه هربا من القصف وانعدام الامن
وقله المياه والغذاء وانقطاعي شبه كامل
للكهرباء
كما ترون انه مسجد بدايه السوق المركزي
تدمر النهائي كل الدكاكين الفستق ما في
دكان من
قوه الانفجار
ناشفه السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبي نسبه
لتعب الشعبي وللمعاناه
في تطور اخر كانت اغارت مقاتله طبيعه
للجيش السوداني على مواقع لقوه الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم واندرمان وتصدت قوه
الدعم السريع لغارات شنها طيران الجيش على
مواقعها في محيط القيادات العامه والقصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم فيما سمع دوي تبادلا
لاطلاق نار في هذه المناطق هذا هو مشطات
قوات الجيش مناطق في محيط مطر الخرطوم
الدولي وفي بحر شمال الخرطوم جددت طائرات
الحربيه قصفها اهدافا للدعم السريع في
ضاحيه كافوري شرقيه بحري وقبل الدعم
السريع انه رد على الهجوم وتمكن من احباط
الهجوم على معسكرها وكبد الجيش خسائر
كبيره وفيون درمان غرب الخرطوم افادت
المعلومات بقصف طيران الجيش منطقه صالحه
ومناطق قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تقع
تمركزات الدعم السريعه
وفيما يخص مبادره ايجاد بشان تسويه
الاوضاع في السودان بين طرفي الصراع نفت
الخارجيه السودانيه التي تتحدث عن تفاوض
الجيش مع الدعم السريع مشيره الى الا صحه
لقبول الجيش بالتفاوض مع الدعم السريع وان
لا خيار امام الدعم السريع سوى الاستسلامه
واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه ان قوات الدعم
السريع مستمره في خروقاتها للهدنه وتعديها
على المدنيين واتخاذهم دروعا بشريه بيان
الخارجيه السودانيه اتهمت دعم السريع
بالاعتداء على المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
وتعطيله عملها
ماذا تضمنت مبادره منظمه الاقليميه
المعنيه بالتنميه في شرق افريقيا ايجاد
تضمنت مقترحات مقتضبه لحل الازمه في
السودان
نصت على تمديد الهدنه الحاليه التي تنتهي
الخميس لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
ودعوه الطرفين المتحاربين لارسال ممثلين
عنهما او مبعوث عسكري الى جوبا جنوب
السودان لاجراء محادثات بينهما ايجاد طلبت
ارسال مندوبي الطرفين الى جوبا يوم الجمعه
المقبل الساعون للمبادره هم رؤساء جنوب
السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي الجيش اعلن
موافقته المبدئيه على المبادره
وترجيحات بان يكون الفريق شمس الدين كباشي
ممثلا للجيش لا تعليق حتى الان من الدعم
السريع بشان المبادره
ومشاهدينا مع تعاقد الوضع في الخرطومه
اصبح الحصول على صور تظهر حجم الدمار امرا
نادرا وكاله رويتر نشرت مجموعه من الصور
المتفرقه التي تم التقاطها اليوم لاثار
المعارك في الخرطوم بحري حيث تظهر مشاهد
دمار بشكل كبير اثر المعارك دعونا نتابع
بعضا من هذه الصور ومن ثم نعود
اظهرت مقاطع مصوره اثارت دمار في منطقه
بري قرب القياده العامه بالخرطوم بعد دخول
قوات الدعم السريع اليها نتابع
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
تدمر الحله كلها
ومشاهدينا مع استمرار المواجهات وتردد
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان وسط استمرار
عمليه الاجلاء تستمر حركه النزوح الداخلي
الى مناطق بعيده عن مواقع الاشتباكات او
الى دول الجوار حيث يستمر الابلاغ عن نزوح
المدنيين في ولايه الخرطوم والولايه
الشماليه والنيل الازرق وشمال كردفان وغرب
دارفور وجنوب دارفور الى جانب التحركات
عبر الحدود الى البلدان المجاوره هذا
وكانت حذرت الامم المتحده من ان ربع مليون
سوداني قد يكونون في طريقهم للهرب برا الى
الدول المجاوره ومن بين الدول السبع
المجاوره للسودان فان اهم التحركات وفق
مفوضيه اللاجئين هي نحو تشاد وجنوب
السودان المفاوضيه اوضحتا الذين شاقوا
طريقهم بانفسهم الى المناطق الحدوديه مع
تشاد يقدر عددهم بنحو 20000 كما انها
تتوقع برا نحو 45 الف لاجئ سوداني جديد
الى جنوب السود ان والى مصر الجار
الشماليه ذكرت المفوضيه ان لديها تقارير
عن بدء نزوح بعض النازحين الى مصر في حين
اعلنت السلطه المصريه ان الاف الاشخاص من
مختلف الجنسيات تمكنوا من الخروج من
السودان الى مصر عبر معبرى قسطل وارقين
حيث يتجاوز عددهم العشره الاف شخص
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه قال ان حكومته تجد صعوبه في
الوصول الى قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
هاتفيا منذ سته ايام
من برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
انه الناس يكونوا يتصلوا في اي وقت
رسلنا
رسلنا له رسلنا البرهان
الرئيس الفقير نيابه عن الدول اللي جات
مشاهدي
نا ان الصراعات السابقه كنت اكدت لنا هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد تشهد هدوء لكن هدوء يبدو
حذر هل تغيرت صوره في هذه الفتره الاخيره
نعم هناك هدوء لكن شاهدوا مجموعه من
السيارات التابعه للجيش السوداني وهي
تنتشر في الجهه الشماليه من ام درمان
قرب من جسر الكبرى للحلفايه شاهد
المواطنين هذه السيارات بحسب شهود عيان
انها سيارات تتبع للجيش السوداني ويبدو
انه استعداد
لمهمه من اجل ما اعلن من قبل ان الجيش
السوداني وقد اعلن الجيش السوداني اكثر من
مره في اليومين الماضيين فيه عمليات
للتمشيط وتطهير المناطق التي تتواجد فيها
قوات الدعم السريعه ربما هذه من ضمن هذه
الخطه بحسب
نفس هذا الجسر الذي كنا كنت كنت تحدثت عنه
سابقا واكدت بان المقابله تتمركز في قوات
الدعم السريع او نتحدث بالجسم اخر
لا لا جسر اخر هو هذا الجسر يقع شمال هذا
الجسر وهو جسر كبر الحفر الجسر الذي
تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل هو جسر شنبات وكلاهما
يربط بين ام درمان وبحري هذا في الجزء
الشمالي من ام درمان وهذا في الجزء
الجنوبي او المنتصف
لكن قال هذا يفهم منه ان الجيش السوداني
ماض في مساله تمشيطه للجيوب التي تنتشر
فيها قوات الدعم السريع وحرص على سلامه
المواطنين بحسب ما اكلت مصادر الى الجيش
لانها ستكون حريصه على حياه المواطنين في
المناطق التي تتواجد بها قوات الدعم
السريع واكدت هذا لاكثر من مره يتزامن مع
الاشتباكات التي تجددت في مناطق اخرى
نجمت عن
مقتل شخصين
حتى هذه اللحظه في الخرطوم
جهه امتداد ناصر وفي بردي وفي هذه
الاقليات برج والمناطق التي هي ليست من
مطار الخرطوم شرقيه مطار الخرطوم
او نتيجه قذائف او ماذا
بحسب ذكره المواطنون هناك وما تواصلنا
معهم انها قوات سريع كانت تحاول ان تدخل
الى الاحياء
هذه القوات كانت يعني في اشتباك مع
السوداني وهي من اصابت هؤلاء المواطنين
بحسب شهود حتى هذه اللحظه لكن الى الان لم
يؤكد هذا الخبر
ان الجيش السوداني لم يصدر بيانا
كذلك عن هذه الاحداث وهي احداث مؤسفه
حقيقه وربما شاهدنا الفيديو قبل قليل عبر
قناه العربيه الذي فيه المواطنون عن هذه
الهجمه بشكل عام ايضا هناك جهه ام درمان
في مناطق محيطه لدعوه التلفزيون
ايضا سمع دليل الرصاص وكذلك
من المضادات في تلك المناطق
محيط التلفزيون وايضا في الاتجاه الجنوبي
الغربي من اندرمان الصالحه كذلك في
المناطق وهي مناطق قوات الدعم السريع في
هذه المنطقه نحن نتابع كذلك بعض الاصداء
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وما يرده
بعضه المراقبين من داخل او بعض المواطنين
السودانيين كان هناك منذ دقائق حديث على
اشتباكات عنيفه هكذا وصفت في اندرمان هل
سمع شيء فيما يخص هذا الموضوع ربما في
منطقه بعيده عنك ولكن هل بلغتك بعض
المعلومات في هذا الاطار سالم
ام عاده هذه الاشتباكات حينما تاتي تصبح
الوصول اليها صعب جدا بحكم الطرق وكذلك
لكن بشكل عام هذه الاشتباكات حينما تكون
الاحياء ربما
تنجم عن يعني مقتل احد المواطنين او
مجموعه من المواطنين كذلك بحكم ان هذه هذه
الاشتباكات اذا كانت في الاحياء وهذا ما
جيش السوداني يحذر منه في العديد من
البيانات
في الاربع ايام الماضيه بالضبط تحدث الجيش
الصيني في اكثر وكذلك من المصادر في داخل
الجيش السوداني بانه يحاولون ابعاد مناطق
الاشتباك من مناطق تواجد المواطنين وحرصا
على سلامتهم وبالفعل هو هذا الامر خطير
اذا كان في الاحياء اذا كانت هذه
الاشتباكات تدور في الاحيان فهي غايه في
الخطوره بحكم ان الاسلحه المستخدمه
تعتبر اسلحه ثقيله وليست من الاسلحه
الخفيفه اس لحه حروب بالفعل وتصلح
للاستخدام في داخل المدينه اصلا وضحت
الفكره نستكون معك تغطيه في نشاطاتنا
القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من ام درمان شكرا لك
ومشاهدينا في اخر تطورات الجهود الدوليه
لاحتواء الازمه في السودان تلقى وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اتصالا من نظيرته الالمانيه حول تطورات في
السودان واكد الوزيران اهميه وقف التصعيد
العسكري وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
السودانيين والمقيمين على ارضه وتوفير
الممرات الانسانيه الامنه للراغبين في
مغادره الاراضي السودانيه
الى ذلك كانت اعلنت مصر ان الجنود
المبذوله لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الاراضي
السودانيه اسفرت عن النجاح في تسهيل عبور
اكثر من 16 الف شخص من غير المصريين الى
داخل الاراضي المصريه حتى اليوم اغلبهم من
السودانيين الذين بلغ عددهم 14 الف مواطن
فر من المناطق التي تشهد مواجهات واعمال
عنف بالاضافه الى اكثر من الفي اجنبي من
50 دوله وست منظمات دوليه
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتح سبتمبر عام 2016 لنقل
البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850 كيلو
مترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه
شاحنه بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من
اشتباكات السودان عبر منه الالاف من
السودانيين والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد
اجتياز المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه
اسوان الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه
بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من
الخرطوم ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان
ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح
للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
[موسيقى]
عبر الاهالي في مدينه ام درمان عن مخاوف
حقيقيه من استمرار عمليه السلب والنهب
بسبب الاقتتال الدائر بين قوات الجيش ودعم
السريع واظهرت لقطه فيديو خاصه بالعربيه
مشاهد تظهر اغلاق المحلات التجاريه في
الاسواق الرئيسيه مع اعاده فتح عدد قليل
منها وسط حذر شديد فيما يطالب الاهالي
الحكومه بتوفير الحمايه اللازمه وبتامين
حياه السكان في ام درمان ووقف اعمال العنف
ودرجه الراعي
واي شارع فيها ناس شغالين شغل مره كسروا
الدكاكين
والشوارع كلها
السوق كله اتكسر
يعني الناس
تتواصل المويه قاطعه الكهرباء قاطعه
لا لا
كده الناس حتى في النهايه
شفتها هنا يا دافع عن
نفسهم لكن الوضع سيء سيء للدرجه بعيده
خلاص في السوق
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذا
العاجل بريطانيا تعلن نقله سفيرها لدى
السودان الى اثيوبيا اذا كما نتابع اسفل
الشاشه بريطانيا تعلن نقله سفيرها لدى
السودان الى اثيوبيا وهناك مواقف دوليه
وهناك تصريحات كذلك الاكيد باننا سنبقى في
متابعتها لحظه بلحظه على مدار اليوم
نتابع مع الرصد وكذلك مع التحليل مع
ضيوفنا من الخرطوم بحري صحفي السوداني
محمد اسحاق عثمان اهلا بك معنا وكذلك من
الخرطوم ينضم لنا الدكتور علاء الدين نقد
المتحدث الرسمي باسمي تجمع المهنيين
السودانيين وعضو المجلس المركزي في قوى
الحريه والتغيير اهلا
بكمين دكتور علاء الدين ساعود لك مع قراءه
اوليه وموقف كذلك لتجمع المهنيين مما يحدث
الان والوسطات ولكن اسمح لي ان استطلع
الاوضاع واقف على ما رصدته سيد محمد اسحاق
عثمان في الخرطوم هناك حديث عن استمرار
الاشتباكات عن سقوط قتيل الخبر لازال ليس
مؤكد ولكن نحن نحاول ان نتحرك الدقه في
نشرها قبل نشره هل هذه الاشتباكات عنيفه
لهذه الدرجه هناك استخدام لاسلحه ثقيله
صحيح
مساء الخير اليوم
البحري الان تشهد هدوء حذر لا سماح في هذه
اللحظات باي صوت هدات الاصوات ذهبا لا تبع
صوت ذوي او انفجارات في البحري باحيائها
المختلفه
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل انتقلت المعركه الى
شرقا النيل والى منطقه كافوري ايضا تشهد
اشتباكات عنيفه في الساعات الماضيه كذلك
انتقل العمليات هذه المره كما علمنا من
مصادر موجوده هناك الى جنوب الخرطوم
وبالتحديد ايضا الى مناطق متفرقه
في خرطوم شمله الصحافات وجبرى وبمنطقه
اللاما بعض الاصابات في منطقه اللاما كما
علمنا قبل قليل لكن اللافت للنظر هنا في
بحري او في مدينه بحري عندما ياتي الليل
تنتشر هذه العصابات
والناس هنا يلزمون بيوتهم لا حركه وسط هذا
السكون لانه هناك عصابات التي
تنشط في مساله السلب وانه كان الجيش قد
اعلن قبل ساعات في ان هناك خطه كبرى يتم
الاعداد
فهو لعل الذي اشار له الزميل الهاشمي قبل
قليل في اسفل الكبري الحلفايه ربما
ما الذي تقصده بخطه للجيش هل هناك عمليه
تمشيط واسعه مثلا نتحدث عنها وماذا
نعمل جيش يتحدث بصوره واضحه عن ان هناك
خطه لتامين ولايه الخرطوم ستكون في
الساعات القادمه
المساله بتاعه النحت والسلب اصبحت مزعجه
جدا حتى مزعجه للجيش الذي هو يعتبر نفسه
بانه مشغول في هذه اللحظات بالعمليات ولكن
مساله السلب والناب ونشاط هذه العصابات
تعلمين بان الاونه الاخيره تم فتح السجون
وخرج كثير من معتاديه لاجرام مما يسبب
سيوله امنيه بطبيعه الحال
بخصوص هذا الموضوع صحيح هناك مخاوف فيما
يخص فرار بعض السجناء ومخاوف كذلك من
عمليات النصب والسلب والسرقه المنتشره كما
يقول مراقبون في الدخل السوداني والان
حضرتك تؤكدها وتتحدث كذلك عن هذه المخاوف
ابقى معي سيد اسحاق دكتور علاء الدين
حضرتك نتابع كما استمعت الى هذه التطورات
ولكن هذه التطورات الميدانيه
كذلك مبادرات وتبدو مبادره ايجاد حتى وان
تباينت المواقف بخصوصها احيانا نستمع بان
الجيش وافق الدعم السريع
امتنع ومن ثم هناك اصوات تدفعه للموافقه
ولكن حضرتك ومن خلالك تجمع المهنيين
السودانيين كيف يقرا هذه المبادره هل هي
قادره فعلا على طرح شيء جدي للحديث
للتفاوض تعتقد
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على سيدنا محمد شكرا لكم على الاستضافه
قناه العربيه
المغفره والرحمه لجميع الشهداء قتلى وعدل
الشفاء للجرحى ودعوات قلبي السودان من هذه
الازمه اول حاجه نحن في تجمع المهنيين من
خلال التجمع او من خلال
مشاركتنا في القوى الحريه والتغيير او
القوه الموقع في الاتفاق الايطالي دائما
ما نرحب بكل المبادرات التي تسعى لحل
الازمه مبادرات الصادقه من الدول
الاقليميه والدول الدوليه الشقيقه
والصديقه دائما نحن منذ بدء الازمه اعلنا
ان هلال الحرب
وانقاذ الدكتور على هناك مبادرات اكيد بان
حضرتكما خلال التجمع المهنيين وكذلك
المجلس المركزي في قوى الحريه والتغيير
يعني تباركون مثل هكذا مبادرات وتهتمون
بامكانيه ان تتواصل الى نهايه اقتتال في
السودان ولكن هناك من بينها مبادرات تثقون
فيها هناك مبادرات يعني تتابعونها ولكن
هناك من بين الاطراف اطراف تثقون بهم من
الاطراف القادره بحسب رايك على طرح مبادره
حقيقيه
طيب نحن اول حاجه طبعا في يعني اطراف قويه
جدا عامله حسي وحقيقه هي حتى الان هي
المسؤوله عن الهدنه الموجوده الان وحتى
وان كان يعني هي غير محترمه كامله لكن
احسن من لا شيء افتكر
المبادره الهدنه الامريكيه حاصل الان التي
بدات يوم الثلاثاء لها القليل من
الانفراجه وايضا يعني مجموعه المجموعه
الرباعيه التي كانت تعمل المدن الاول في
العمليه السياسيه ايضا لها يعني تدخلات
السعوديه عندما قدمت مبادرتها ايضا يعني
رحبنا بها وايضا الان مبادره الايجاد
متابعين للاحداث
الحاصله فيها ولكن يعني فقط بنبادر يعني
لاحظ انه في تقلب في في قبول مبادرات من
طرفي النزاع يعني
صحيح وهذا ما لاحظه البعض ولكن اسمح لي
دكتور علاء حضرتكم لستم فقط مراقبين يعني
هذا الكلام يمكن ان يقولها صحافي عهدي
انتم مكون سياسي مهم جدا في داخل السوداني
طيب الدخل السوداني مهم كذلك في طرح مثل
هكذا المبادرات هل تتفاعلون هل تناقشون
طرفي النزاع طبعا اكيد اليوم الاول
المواصلين طرفي النزاع يعني حتى
الخارجيه السودانيه وتقول ان ليس هناك
جهودنا وعلى المليشه الاستسلام والفناء
غريبه جدا كونه انه الخارجيه السودانيه
تصبح مثل الناطق الرسمي للجيش فهي غريبه
جدا يعني كل المراقبين استغربوا لهذا
الموقف يعني كان الجيش يصرح لوحده عنده
ناطق رسمي ولديه قادته يصرحون لكن ان تصبح
الخارجيه السودانيه
يعني حضرتك تطالب بتحيد لمؤسسات السياديه
في داخل السوداني على الاقل تبقى هذه
المؤسسات على نفس المسافه من كل هذه
الاطراف ساعود لك دكتور اكيد ساعود لك
فيما يخص هذه النقطه ونقاط اخرى ساعود
للصحفي كذلك محمد اسحاق عثمان ولكن بعد
التذكير ببعض الاخبار المتعلقه بهذه
التطورات وفي اخرها كانت اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه تمكنت مساء
اليوم من اجلاء 200 شخص
رعايه الدول الشقيقه والصديقه من السودان
الى جده واضافت الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اجماليه من تم اجلائهم من السودان منذ بدء
العمليه وصل الى نحو
1744 شخصا منهم وتسعه عشر سعوديا والباقون
من 76 جنسيه واكدت السعوديه ان الاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم اليوم هم من امريكا ومصر
والبحرين والصومال ولبنان وافغانستان
وفلسطين والصومال كذلك كنا ذكرناها
وجامبيا ونيجيريا وباكستان وكندا
وتايلاندا على ضهر سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض العربيه تواكب وصول رعايه القادمين
من السودان هذه السفينه التي تحمل على
متنها اكثر من 200 شخص وصلت للتو الى
قائده الملك فيصل البحريه وهي وقفت بالفعل
بشكل تام وها هي هذه اللحظات الان في
انتظار النزول لكن هناك بروتوكول بحري
معروف لدى القوات اي او اي قوه بحريه هي
بصعود قائد الاسطول ويحيي الطاقم الملاحي
للسفينه ويحييهم ايضا لوصوله او سلامه
وصولهم وعلى الانجاز الذي حققوا اذا ايضا
ننقل الصوره من الجهه الاخرى وهي سوره
وصول الرعايه الذين وصلوا من جنسيات
مختلفه اسيويه وكذلك افريقيه وايضا بعض
الجنسيات الاوروبيه التي وصلت على هذه
اللحظات وهم قادمين بومبورت سودان
وهي سفينه قد غادرت ليله امس ووصلت في هذه
اللحظات
مشاهدينا يتجدد القتال في اقليم دارفور
المطرب غرب السودان يبدو انه اتخذ ابعادا
قبليه معارك عنيفه والشبكات وصفاتها الامم
المتحده بالدميه شهدتها مدينه الجنينه
عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور على مستوى هذه
النقطه من الخريطه بين عناصر الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع مستخدمين مختلفه انواع
الاسلحه القتال العنيف تحول الى النزاع
بين قبيلتين وهي قبيله المساليد الافريقيه
وفي المقابل القبائل العربيه واستخدمت في
هذا النزاع الاسلحه الثقيله عشرات القتلى
من المدنيين سقطوا مئات الجرحى اصيبوا ولم
يتم اسعافهم بسبب صعوبه الاوضاع الامنيه
وانتشار المسلحين القبليين في اجزاء واسعه
من مدينه الجنينه عدا عن تزايد اعمال نهب
للمؤسسات الحكوميه ومقارا منظمه الامنيه
وسوق الجنينه وحرق عدد كبير من الم
الوافقه مسؤولين في حكومه غرب دارفور الى
جانب توزيع الاسلحه بين المجتمعات المحليه
ما يزيد من الفوضى والعنف هذه التطورات
دفعت بعدد من سكان الجنينه الى الفرار
باتجاه الحدود السودانيه على مستوى هذا
الخط من تشاد او مسودان الى باتجاه تشاد
رغم اغلاق الحكومه هناك للحدود ومنذ عقدين
يعيش اقليم دارفورث اضطرابات امنيه كبيره
تخللتها انتهاكات واسعه تسببت بمقتل قرابه
الثلاثه الف شخص وتسببت بنزوحي مليونين
وخمسمائه الف شخصا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عاود من جديد الى ضيوف يا دكتور علاء
الدين نقض المتحدث الرسمي باسم تجمع
المهني السودانيين وعضو المجلس المركزي في
قوى الحريه والتغيير واعود كذلك الى ضيفه
من الخرطوم بحري الصحفي السوداني محمد
اسحاق عثمان واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
الخرطوم بحري مع سيد محمد سيد محمد كنا
نعرض جزءا مما يشهده اقليم دارفور من
حالات نزوح ولجوء الى اخره ولكن الخرطوم
كذلك كان شهد عمليات نزوح باتجاه مناطق
معينه وولايات مختلفه هل عمليه نزوح لا
زالت مستمره يمكن ان تحدثنا عن بعض
التفاصيل لتضعنا في اطار هذه الساعات
الاخيره وما يحدث خلالها
نعم بالتوازي مع عمليات الادلاء التي تتم
للرعايه الاجانب في السودان او في الخرطوم
بالتحديد كذلك ما زالت النزوح هي لا زالت
مستمره او الهجره الى والعوده الى
الولايات هذه واحده من الاشكالات ايضا
التي يعاني منها المواطن السوداني استغلال
ضعاف النفوس
لمساله التعليميه هذه المجالات تتم عبر
حافلات وبصات مخصصه
او لعودتهم الى الولايات الناس
يشتكونها من القناه الفاحش واستغلال ضعاف
النفوس للظرف برفع التذاكر
نعم مضبوط ولكن هذه المساله ايضا لا يعني
لا يعاقب بها المواطن الذي هو يحاول
الاصرار من هذه النيران ومن هذه
الاشتباكات يعني المواطنه الان السوداني
نعم مقلوب على على امره كما تعلمين ولكن
ايضا
بالمتابعات تابعنا قبل قليل الخبر الذي
اوردتموه حول معاناه السودانيين ايضا
المتواجدين في معبر اربيل هناك الذين
يودون ايضا
الذهاب الى جمهوريه مصر الشقيقه على كل
حال نرصد في كل يوم
معاناه انسانيه بشكل مختلف
وطعم مختلف المواطن الاذاعه اسمح لي فقط
ان اشير الى هذا العاجل عن الخليج
البريطانيه التي تتحدث عن اجلاء نحو 900
شخص من السودان اليوم الخارجيه البريطانيه
تقول تم اجلاء نحو 900 شخص من السودان
اليوم سيد اسحاق ساعود لك ولكن اسمح لي ان
نشارك معنا كذلك ضيفنا من الخرطوم الدكتور
على الدين دكتور حضرتك تعلم بانه الازمه
الانسانيه متفاقمه في السودان وزادت حده
منذ بدا هذه الصراعات او هذه الاشتباكات
بين الدعم السريع وقوات
والجيش السوداني ولكن كذلك تعلم بان
المجتمع المدني في داخل السوداني مجتمع
قوي
حضرتك
كممثل لتجمع المهنيين السودانيين وكذلك
عضو في قوى الحريه والتغيير اكيد بانكم
تتفاعلون او على الاقل تتواصلون مع
المجتمع المدني القادر على المساعده هل
هذا حصل وما هي تفاصيل خدماتكم التي انتم
قادرون ان تقدموها في هذه الاوقات الصعبه
طيب شكرا على السؤال حقيقه نحن متفاعلين
بصوره قويه جدا مع المجتمع المدني والان
تبلور الجبهه مدنيه عريضه لمعاهده الحرب
في المجتمع المدني سيعلن عنها قريبا وغير
ذلك منذ بدايه الحرب تم يعني جميع الفئات
الموجوده في التجمع المهنيين وبالذات
الكوادر الطبيه والصحيه انخرطت في غرف
الطوارئ الموجوده على مستوى المدن الثالث
وحتى على الاقاليم لتوفير المعينات
المواطنين الموجودين في منازلهم او مثلا
عن طريق الاطباء للوجود في المستشفيات
ودعوات ونداءات المناشده للحضور اليهم
والاتصال مع المنظمات الدوليه والمنظمات
الاقليميه لتوفير المعينات والادويه
والمستهلكات الطبيه ولكن هناك اتصالات
قويه جدا قد نجحت في تكوين هذه الجبهه
المدنيه العريضه الحرب حقيقه وسوف الدوله
شكرا عنها قريبا ايضا في حالات ولكن لماذا
قريبا الدكتور اسمح لي لماذا قريب لماذا
لم يجهز ذلك لانه نحن دخلنا على تقريبا
اليوم هو اليوم
الثاني عشر او الثالث عشر
اليوم يكون حقيقه هي لانه النظره التي
كثرت يعني المنظمات
منها على الرغم من تبعتها قليلا السياسي
لكن نجحنا في اختراق هذا الاختلاف السياسي
والتاكيد على مبدا مناهضه الحرب حقيقه
التاكيد على المبدا الحرب كان فيها العديد
من المحيطات تحديدا يعني فنون النظام
البائده وعناصر النظام البائد الموجودين
في الحياه الاجتماعيه والحياه المدنيه
ومثل ما هم موجودين في الحياه العسكريه هم
الذين كانوا يؤجدون نهر الحرب
حتى من
ايام السياسيه والان حتى بعد الحرب هم
الذين يدعون لا تكون هناك هدنه وقف في
الاطلاق
صحيح التغلب على ان اسال في هذا الاطار
دكتور لاني يعني هناك احساس من خلال كلام
حضرتك بانك على بعد نفس المسافه من
الطرفين الطرفين سواء الدعم السريع او
الجيش السوداني كلاهما يتحدث عن ان الطرف
الاخر فيه من فلول النظام من يدفعون
بتازيم اكبر لهذه
الصراع اين الحقيقه اين الحقيقه لم نجد لم
نجد من طرف الجيش من يتحدث عن عن فلول
النظام السابق ولكن وجدنا ان فلول النظام
السابق وبالذات رموز النظام السابق الذين
خرجوا من سجن كوبر وعلى راسهم احمد هارون
ببيان يقول انه يصطف مع الجيش وانهم قد
خرجوا
وينحاش وما الى هذا حقيقه راينا هذا
البيان واعتقد يعني عرضتم وتحدثت عنه وهذا
البيان حقيقه يتفق
حتى هارون انه قد تم حبسنا لارضاء لجهاز
سياسيه وايضا الجيش قال ان المعتقين هم
معتقلون سياسيا وتجاوز عن ان هؤلاء
المعتقلون ليسوا فقط
الدوليه الجنائيه الدوليه لديهم جرائم حرب
يعني يحاسبوا عليها
فاهرب الذي بين سلول النظام او
رموزها الجيش حقيقه يؤكد ان هناك عناصر من
النظام البائد داخل الجيش هي من ضجه
بالبلاد الى هذا الحرب الى هذه الحرب وهذه
المعركه
اسمح لي ان انقلها للسيد محمد اسحاق سيد
محمد اسحاق منذ قليل كنت تحدثت على خطوره
هروب بعض المسجونين وتحدثت كذلك عن عمليات
السلب والسرقه المنتشره ما الذي يجب فعله
لوقف هذا النزيف في هذا التوقيت الحرج
وباختصار ان سمحت
نعم طبعا نكتفي مع الدكتور بان الوضع الان
اصبح اكثر تازيما خصوصا وخروج
الانصار النظام البائد وهذه التصريحات
التي اصبحت
مباشره بطبيعه الحال تؤخذ هذه التصريحات
في هذا التوقيت بالتحديد وتصنف بانها من
التصريحات او البيانات المستفزه لان الوقت
في الان في الوقت الحالي البلاد تعيش في
هذا في وضع من الحرب والارتباك الواضح في
كل التفاصيل
على المستوى السياسي نعلم بانه هناك غياب
تام لان الوضع الان لا يسمح بالتدخل
المعركه وفي حاله حرب والناس تعاني
الامرين من الحصول على ابسط شيء على يعني
الاحتياجات اليوميه
ونقول بان هذه من المعضلات الاساسيه التي
سيدفع ثمنها بطبيعه الحال هذا الشعب
السوداني سواء كان خروج السياسي
ين خروج يعني هؤلاء المجرمين الذين هم
بعضهم محكوم عليه لدرجه البعض محكوم عليه
بالاعدام سنكتفي بهذا القدر على ان نعود
ونناقش كل ذلك في نشرات قادمه اود شكرا
لكم جزيلا شكرا من الخرطوم بحري الصحفي
السوداني محمد اسحاق عثمان والشكر كذلك
لضيفه من الخرطوم الدكتور علاء الدين نقد
المتحدث الرسمي باسم تجمع المدنيين
السودانيين وعضو المجلس المركزي في قوى
الحريه والتغيير شكرا لكم
نتابع دائما في تغطيه هذه الاحداث وهذه
الازمه حيث قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
قال ان الوضع في السودان قد يتفاقم في
الايام المقبله كما اكد على ان بلاده
ستواصل الدعمه للرعايه البريطانيه
وقف اطلاق النار ليس مقدمه بالضروره
للسلام والوضع في السودان من الممكن ان
يتفاقم في الايام المقبله ونحن سنواصل
الدعم للرعايه البريطانيين لذلك نحن
موجودون في بورتودان ولدينا مسؤولون
دبلوماسيون في مصر واثيوبيا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وقبل ذلك كان دعاك الرعايه البريطانيين في
السودان الى الالتحاق برحلات الجويه دون
تاخير مشيرا الى بريطانيا قد لا تكون
قادره على مواصله عمليه الاجلاء عندما
ينتهي وقف اطلاق النار
حان الوقت للتحرك لدينا الطائرات والقدرات
وايضا هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لذلك نقول
للناس اذا كنتم تريدون الحصول على دعمنا
للسفر خارج السودان فافعلوا ذلك الان
يمكننا تسهيل خروجكم ربما سيقرر بعض
الاشخاص لاسباب خاصه البقاء حتى عندما يتم
وقف اطلاق النار لكننا نقول هناك رحلات
جويه واذا كنت ترغب في السفر فهذا هو افضل
وقت للقيام بذلك
ومشاهدينا مع استمرار ازمه في السودان
هناك توقعات بنزوح وهروب اعداد مهوله من
السودانيين صحيفه تيلغراف تقول ان
بريطانيا قد تشهد موجه نزوحا كبيره بينما
تتوقع الامم المتحده نزوح الاف السودانيين
الى دول مجاوره مثل تشاد وجنوب السودان
[موسيقى]
الازمه في السودان موجه هجره جديده صحيفه
التلغراف البريطانيه تتوقع نزوح اعداد
مهوله من السكان وبالتالي زياده في عدد
المهاجرين غير النظاميين
فبريطانيا وحدها قد تشهد لجوء اعداد كبيره
من السودانيين الامم المتحده تقول ان عددا
كبيرا من اللاجئين السودانيين فروا الى
بلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الازمه مع توقعات
بنزوح مئه الف سوداني الى تشاد
و170 الفا الى جنوب السودان بالاضافه الى
مصر وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
بدورها تناشد الامم المتحده جميع الدول
بجوار السودان ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الذين يبحثون عن الاماني والحمايه
[موسيقى]
دعت روسيا اضراف النزاع الى ضبط النفس
الناطقه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه دعت الى اتخاذ خطوات عاجله
لوقف اطلاق النار وقالت ان الاحداث
الماساويه التي يشهدها السودان تثير قلق
موسكو التي تتخذ كافه الاجراءات اللازمه
لضمان سلامه رعاياها في السودان وامكانيه
تنفيذ اجراءات الاجلاء
[تصفيق]
ولاول مره تكشف روسيا رسميا عن دور قوه
فاكنير في السودان بعد ان اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه ان للسودان الحق في
الاستفاده من خدمات فاجنر كيف عززت روسيا
حضورها في السودان متابع التفاصيل
الصراع في السودان يفتح باب مواجهه جديده
بين روسيا والغرب وموسكو تكشف رسميا ولاول
مره عن دور مجموعه فاجنر هناك وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ومن المقر الاممي في
نيويورك كشف ان للسودان الحق في الاستفاده
من خدمات فاغنر فضلا عن كلامي لافروف رئيس
فارنير اكد استعداد مجموعته للتدخل في حال
طلب الشعب السوداني ذلك
السودان سكيناروتو براتي الشعب السوداني
فسارسل بالتاكيد مهمه حفظ سلام الى
السودان من قبل شركه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه ولو كانت فاجنر هناك اعتقد ان
الحرب لم تكن لتبدا في السودان فاجنر لا
تبدا الحروب انما تنهيها دائما
موسكو اسست لوجودها في السودان منذ عهد
البشير من خلال تحسين شروط عمل شركات
الطاقه الروسيه واخرى تنشط في مجال
التنقيب عن الذهب والثروات الاخرى ايضا
ابرز ما عزز الوجود الروسي في السودان هو
سلاح الذي اصبحت بسببه المصدر الرئيسي
للجيش السوداني فتحولت الخرطوم الى ثاني
شريك عسكريا لروسيا في القاره الافريقيه
بعد الجزائر بعد تلك الخطوات وتحديدا عام
وقع السودان اتفاقا مع روسيا لانشاء قاعده
عسكريه على البحر الاحمر تستضيف سفنا
روسيه بما في ذلك سفن تعمل بالوقود النووي
على ان يتمركز فيها 300 جندي اتفاق اثار
قلق الغرب بدوره في تعزيز الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه في افريقيا وعلى سو البحر الاحمر
ورغم وقف العمل بالاتفاقيه بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير الى ان مصالح موسكو في السودان
دفعتها الى الابقاء على علاقه وثيقه مع
اللاعبين الاساسيين خلال السنوات الماضيه
لكن تميزت مع احمدتي خصوصا على خلفيه
تزايد التقارير حول امداد قواته بالسلاح
والمساعده العسكريه الروسيه من خلال قوات
فاجنر محاسن حضاره العربيه
وفي جديده التطورات الميدانيه رصد مراسل
العربيه خلو الشوارع في المنطقه الرابطه
بين الخرطوم بحري وام درمان مع وجود قوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه الان اقف هنا
في صينيه اسماعيل الازهري وهذا منزل اول
رئيس وزراء للحكومه السودان في هذه
المنطقه ليست ببعيده من جسر شنبات الرابط
هذا الاسم
وعسكع لقوات الدعم السوات الدعم السريعي
تتمركز بهذا الجسم الان ولي
الطريقه الاخر من هنا يؤدي الى الهيئه
القوميه للاذاعه والتلفزيون التي تتجدد
فيها الاشتباكات في مدينه ام درمان ربما
هذه المنطقه الان كما نراها هادئه لكن
السكان هنا يشكون من هلع وتوتر بحكم ان
هذه المنطقه بالتحديد يسمع فيها اصوات ذوي
للمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه وفي هذه المنطقه
بالضبط يسمع ايضا مضادات او طائرات بين
الفينه والاخرى اصبحت خاليه تماما من
السكان الا نزرا يسيرا وهم الان يحذروننا
من الوقوف في هذه المنطقه بقناتي العربيه
والحدث سالم الهاشمي من مدينه ام درمان
هذا هو كانت اظهرت مقاطع مصوره اثار
الدمار في منطقه بري قرب القياده العامه
بالخرطوم بعد دخول قوه الدعم السريعي
اليها
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
تدمر الحله كلها في حاجه ثانيه
نرصد الاوضاع من بورتسودان هذه المره مع
صحفي عبد القادر بكاش عبد القادر اهلا بك
معنا هل فعلا خفت وتيره وصول النازحين الى
بورتسودان او هي نفسها منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه
مستمره
الخروج من السودان هناك ترتيبات تتم في
نادي هيئه المانيا البحريه لعدد من
السفارات
والداليات والقناه هناك مجهودات مقدره
تتميز في مطار برشلونه وفي نادي حيه
الموان البحريه
عبد القادر هم قادمون فقط من الخرطوم او
من ولايات اخرى
اغلب القادمون الان غادمون ولايه الخرطوم
وحتى الان حجم النزاع بين القوات القوات
الدعم الثري والقوات المسلحه في نت جدا في
ولايه الخرطوم بقيه الولايات باستثناء
ولايات دارفور تشهد استقرار
مجهول وكبير جدا لم يعني تحدث اي هزه
امنيه في اي من ولايات السودان ال18
باستثناء ولايه الخرطوم وبعض ولايات
دارفور يدور بها قتال بين القوتين لكن بعض
السودان الان عامل ومستغل لذلك لم نرشد
توافد اي اجانب او
موظفين بعتاد دبلوماسيه من اماكن خارج
الخرطوم
الطريق من الخرطوم الى بورت سودان يقول
البعض بانه يشهد الشبكات متقطعه بين فتره
واخرى هل هذا مستمر والى اي مدى هذا
الطريق قادر ان يكون مؤمن حتى
ينتهيجه او يتخذه النازح
في يوم 15 يوم الاشتباك الاول بين القوتين
واليوم الذي اليومين الذي طلته كانت هناك
مخاوف على الطريق وهناك بعض الجيوب من
قوات الدعم الشهيد زهره على منطقه الجيلي
وشندي وهي مناطق بعيده جدا من ولايه البحر
الاحمر وهي مناطق متاقمه لولايه الخرطوم
لكن باستثناء
الاحداث في اليومين الاوائل لم يشهد
الطريق القومي البري الرابط بين العاصمه
والميناء اي اشتباكات او محددات امنيه
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد القادر بكاشه الصحفي
كنت معنا من بورتسودان
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نختم هذه الساعه من التغطيه
بموجز لابرز الاخبار الدوليه وفي اخر
التطورات كانت اعلانات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن توجيه ضربه مركزه باسلحه بحريه
عاليه الدقه على مواقع تمركز احتياطات
القوات الاوكرانيه وفي السياق ذاته فدت
الدفاع الروسيه انها قوتها سيطرت على عده
مناطق جديده في الضواحي الشماليه
والجنوبيه
مؤكده على ان الجيش الروسي ابسط سيطرته
على اربعه احياء جديده في بخموت
قال امين عام حلف الناتو قال ان اعضاء
الحلف قدموا دعما غير مسبوقا لاوكرانيا
وان الدعم الغربيه لاوكرانيا سيجعلها بوضع
قوي لمواصله استعاده اراضيها
بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحده قدم اعضاء
النيتو دعما غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا وتم
بالفعل تسليم اكثر من
98% من المركبات القتاليه التي وعدت بها
اوكرانيا وهذا يعني اكثر من
1550 عربه مدرعه و230 دبابه ومعدات اخرى
بما في ذلك كميات هائله من الذخيره كما
قمنا بتدريب وتجهيز اكثر من تسع كتائب
مدرعه اوكرانيه جديده وهذا سيضع اوكرانيا
في وضع قوي لمواصله استعاده اراضيها
المحتله
اكد وزير الخارجيه الصينيه تشينج اكد ان
اول محادثه هاتفيه بين رئيس الصيني مع
نظيره الاوكرانيه
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه تعد خطوه مهمه
نحو تسويه سياسيه للازمه كما قال مشيرا
الى ان الخطوه التي اتخذتها الصين تمثل
مدى التزام الدوله الثابت بالحياديه قائلا
ان موقف الصيني يعزز عمليه السلام
والمفاوضات
اكد رئيس روسيا ان دول النميه تعاني اكثر
من غيرها بسبب العقوبات المفروضه على
تصدير الاسمده الروسيه مؤكدا خلال اجتماع
مع رئيس الرابطه الروسيه لمنتجي الاسمده
ان العقوبات على بلاده كما فرضها من قبل
الدول التي لا تحتاج الى الاسمده مشيرا
الى ان الاسواق الناميه في افريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه واسيا تضررت بشكل كبير
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه ان الحرس الثوريه
الايراني يحتاج ناقله نفط ترفع علم جزر
مارشال مطالبه بالافراج الفوري عنها وقال
الاسطول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه ان
الحرس الثوريه الايرانيه احتجزا ناقله
النفط اثناء عبورها في المياه الدوليه في
خليج عمان مطالبا الحكومه الايرانيه
بالافراج عنها فورا بدورها قالت البحريه
الايرانيه ان ناقله حاولت الفرار بعد
اصطدامها بزورق ايراني ما اسفر عن فقدان
شخصين واصابه اخرين مشيرتان الى ان
مدمرتان ايرانيه اوقفت ناقله واقتدتها
للسواحل الايرانيه
تدرس الحكومه البلجيكيه تسليمه دبلوماسيا
ايرانيا محكوما بسجن الى ايران وقال رئيس
الوزراء البلجيكي انها حكومته تدرس طلبا
رنيا بتسليم الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه اسد
الله اسدي المحكومه بالسجن عشرين عاما
مقابل افراج طهران عن عامر اغاثه بلجيكي
يقضي عقوبه السجن لمده 40 عاما بتهمه
التجسس واذن اسد بتخطيط لهجوم على تجمع
المعارض لنظام طهران في فرنسا عام 2018
ظهر رئيس تركي رجب طيب اردوغان على شاشه
تلفزيونيه لاول مره بعد مرضيه وذلك بحسب
ما نقلت وكاله الوكاله الفرنسيه حيث شارك
اردوغان في اجتماع عبر الفيديو مع نظيره
الروسي
للحديث عن مساهمه روسيا في انشاء محطه
للطاقه النوويه في جنوب تركيا وكان
اردوغان تعرض لي وعكه صحيه اثناء بث مباشر
للقاء على الهواء ما اثار تساؤلات حول
حالته الصحيه
تبنى مجلس نواب الباكستاني مشروع قرار
بتاكيد الثقه التامه برئيس الوزراء محمد
شهبا الشريف كزعما للاغلبيه النيابيه
ورئيسا للحكومه الائتلافيه وحصل شهبه
الشريف على تاييد اغلبيه اعضاء مجلس
النواب بدعم 180 نائبا من اصل 342 وهو عدد
مقاعد مجلس النواب المطلوب لتاكيد الثقه
كما يعد هذا العدد اكبر من مجموع الاصوات
التي حصل عليها الشريف عند حصوله على ثقه
مجلس النواب في شهر ابريل العمل الماضي
حيث حصل على 140 صوتا
قال الرئيس الامريكي والسابق دونالد ترامب
ان الرئيس جو بايدن يشكل خطرا على
الديمقراطيه بحسب قوله واضافات راب على
صفحته على موقع
قال ان بايدن غير كفو ولا يعرف كيف يدير
البلاد واعتبر الرئيس السابق ان الولايات
المتحده في حاله تدهور خطير بسبب قياده
شخص عظيم الجدوى على حد تعبيره
صدمت او صدت الشرطه الفرنسيه حشدا من
المتظاهرين المناهضين لاصلاح نظام التقاعد
قرابه احد القصور في شرق فرنسا ويتواجد
رئيسا والماكرون في هذا القصر الذي يقع
على الحدود الفرنسيه مع سويسرا للاحتفال
بالذكرى المئه وال 175 لالغاء الرق في
فرنسا
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذا
العاجل والتطور المهم كذلك نختم به هذه
الساعه الجيش السوداني يعلن تمديد الهدنه
72 ساعه للعمليات الانسانيه ولاجلاء
الاجانب اذا الجيش السوداني يعلن تمديد
الهدنه 72 ساعه نحن اساسا كنا في هدنه
تختتم اليوم المفروض كانت 72 ساعه وتم
تمديدها 72 ساعه اخرى يقول الجيش بان هذه
الهدنه ستكون للعمليات الانسانيه ولاجلاء
الاجانب سنبقى في متابعه هذا التطور
وسنكمل هذه التغطيه هذه سعه انتهت ولكن
بعد قليل تلقاكم زميلتي الليالي لتتابع
معكم كل هذه التفاصيل ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات